okay I meant to go hello everyone
welcome to today's live broadcast how to
meet the challenge of counting and
analyzing tumor cells circulating in the
peripheral blood presented to you by
today's keynote speaker dr. jacinto
skulls I'm Christina jewel of lab roots
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning we
have a few important announcements
before we begin this webcast is designed
to be interactive and we encourage you
to ask questions during the event you
can submit questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window we
will try to answer as many questions as
we can you can enlarge the slide window
by clicking on the screen icon in the
lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you have any technical
problems viewing or hearing this
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of your
presentation window or you can submit
your problems through the green Q&A
button on the lower left this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
continuing education credits after the
webinar is over please click on the c/e
button located in the bottom left hand
corner of your web page and follow the
process of obtaining your credit I would
now like to introduce today's speaker
dr. Giacinto schools do simple schools
is donner professor of science emeritus
at princeton university distinguished
adjoint professor in the department of
physics and biology at Temple University
an Associated member of the nanotech
Institute of the National res council of
Italy and leche Italy his career has
spanned in unusually long length of time
and Antonin an equally unusually broad
range of subjects that ranges from
a spectroscopy to molecular beams from
surface science to superfluid HD
droplets and from biomech biomolecular
nano sensing to medical diagnostics he
has received several recognitions her
her Spock prize in 2013 the gold medal
of honor of the Italian chemical society
the ben franklin medal for physics in
2006 two honorary doctorates 1997 and
2000 the divided price of the acs the
plyler prize of the aps and the
lippincott award of the osa he is a
fellow of the APS osa of the royal
society of the UK and of the Royal
Science Academy of the Netherlands KN aw
he has published about 300 papers in
peer-reviewed journals and he has been
quoted by his colleagues approximately
nineteen thousand times his age ndex is
74 he has supervised about a hundred PhD
students an unusually high percentage of
which now covers positions of
responsibility in academia and research
I will now turn it over to dr. schools
for his presentation dr. schools yes
yeah I'm so then a subject of today's
metabolic phenomena a basis for nominate
city sees like to convince you by the
end of this talk that liquid biopsies if
they are being called at present I have
been coming and they will revolutionize
it diagnostic three cancer for into
there is a mini-review house now dry
first canceled letters that makes
exactly same point they also char
Martone and I'll and the city season
early breast cancer the pass was taking
the titration you can find it there on
the web okay in the first license like
to tell you so all this is this work was
done in the framework of an ear she
European search council grant
I got five years ago began to the
finished and a second grant called a
cactus because the same proof of concept
grant where we get some money to proof
one of the concepts developed between
the fundamentals worker and you're doing
the quick go home and wait our group is
coral is a molecular nanotechnology for
life science applications it's been
working right 5 years 10 years 20 demon
well johnny 17 may be moving to nanotech
it to deserve a little e this is a
national council of italy ok
consultation today this is the gnostic
link i present you get a beginner way no
traffic they came at Le Pew cycle you
tricked you chemotherapy drugs and then
after a few weeks eight weeks or you you
go for the end of the tools to see if
they r a disease has been progressing or
not which is very slow and expensive to
do but then if you look for city sees
secretly cells in the peripheral blood
spend much less money after one week you
have an answer is the chemotactic
factors working or not because it says
number remains constant oh Jesus and you
know it's not working they go down
twerking therefore you can really make
provision one week versus eight weeks or
even ten sixteen weeks sometimes and
therefore it you can block with after
this before they form not after their
form which is essential for survival of
the patient
okay this city sees can be counted in
breast cancer colorectal cancer process
most cancers have CDC's brain cancer
don't have then a lot from brain cancer
do everything she sees it no she's not
available everywhere to count them
that's the problem because this
technique is used very very seldomly
quite clearly they're not seeing the
weak link in cancer care because limited
sensitivity is slow and often expensive
currently in security tumor cells can be
faster and more sensitive there are very
few days events and maybe 22 more cents
per 10 29 both cells which is really
event but if you can are able to count
them i will show you can we count the
moment you get proud of this prediction
their proficiency and potentially
information cdcs relation genomic
sensitivity resistance which is very
important that's what the taxi should do
typically sofa near by al in 204 make a
fundamental paper and the staff said is
filled basically it was seven ripped off
the ball in 28 claim 28 traps in 212
blanking science to Cecina very
important with you if you then establish
counting with a lot of each patient
establishing a certain drug can work or
not then you you stablish the basis of
what's called personal medicine however
sermon is really a useful concept for
will require very large cause of
patients and they just work and it's not
even sure you will establish yourself
very fast but you can take group of
patients certified patient in groups and
then when they're common
phenotypes you can make dinner statement
for those whole group and I can tell if
he wishes good for the whole group is
kind of personal medicine and not quite
personalized that's going to work much
earlier Hank and establish it would
clinical practice in the near future in
my opinion so why is this the original
technology for the unity of practice the
gold standard missile is a very diverse
in videos until recently the x-bike dos
anjos mitosis is even a we have an item
on the Sentry antibodies being
terminated on the particles and struck
them encounter and tricks them into a
show straight and count them XM
typically at some antibodies are used it
links to manatee nanoparticles and if
those are have been used only if you
tell yourself I'll come to because Holly
kill yourself express up come antibodies
can be obtained with activities on the
nanoparticles
but we know we showed the rest of this
talk till it was a camel transition
quite self cannot be counted so that's a
big problem it's why certain cancers
show very little secret do or say
whatever they may be much more soccer
discuss a bit about the Ducati two more
major cause of cancer is the most
allottees to move metathesis that's can
differ greatly from parent or you should
double genetic characteristics let's
continue the consulship therapy making
biopsy from a 30-person patient
elevation and basic procedure and pretty
impossible to the lack of a sexual
legends after the Gnostic is very clink
too slow and too expensive take a
performance to see energies working or
not it was a review to tend to Twitter
Dean Sydney's concert very clearly so
we'll be nice to have a cheap and
dialogue as their nursery two years ago
absolutely students in my group and
first two ND students popular event
method for it has to come up with a
proposal for such a tool to expect the
proposed to me to ease the temperature
with every email a cure for cancer me we
might be surprised no one thought about
just that also studies about how to buy
them okay biology of this self put
differently fundamental search making
the normal tissue and therefore the idea
was and says forward no one is also come
cities issues using their then my camel
image my mac why because lasik deficit
then they die college changes you know
full-on tercel momentum change type
a metabolic phenomenon called the Bible
I be known for about sunder das armas
and it's ending the difference in body
established between differentiated
tissue and into most issues even
envision caesars most of the energy of
them the glucose goes into producing a
PPS so point to the energy or the power
or the cells actually oxidative
phosphorylation produces the sequel of
ATP for one Marvel glucose a lobby for
colleges in differentiated tissue said
to Monica YTP purmamarca Lulu course I
said yes too much it took a different of
course prescrip you wait for a steak
depending on what is the tissue lactate
ish basic acidic and then the processor
he also a self very fast ashleigh
testified environment around them but
every one or more over that ring too
much hello city came back cannot be
determine that because first of all US
cellular city of lake toba should opt to
do and various a law practice self
walking swimming to the blood graduated
and you can measure yeah a metabolism
sugar it and if you spend if you enjoyed
the cell little drop of water or broth
and you can see the acidification goes
on into the blood and is not a rooted
into the rock your body so you can see
it
the working principles are for protect
pH changes in the extracellular
environment in single cell level you can
do that by interpreting every single
size drop we can interpret it by making
a tangle microfluidic cell and in the 50
micron cell typical eaters you ever send
it in a droplet and you can make it flow
Nevada X says search apparatus
principles process question a visible we
are going to the text metabolic
differences in pic adopted spectrum of
the texts in epithelial cells very
narrow for us every orphan types of the
same by Boog effect is the cancer cells
no plastic will do it in there for
speculation Francis broad you'll need to
know which type of phenotype like the
cell we a control a lancer if this
moreover they white blood cells may also
respond a bit to acidification but
another mindful it's listen online left
and cancel service congratulations not
possible a seller fix it will be
cultured in city that swimming rod you
can separate the self till then such the
genomics of it and see face the genome
is changing from the metathesis from the
primary one and therefore we can see it
as Pacific drugs developing or not the
cost is ratio arrows testing 50 hours 10
hours or so and you how you can
carefully the cost well radix point cost
five endeavors not terribly expensive
but still something and make a little
closer time the day
osas ladies is that Senate app
centimeters of the plastic pail blood
and go to the microfiche I could put a
microscope invest the microscope and you
can interrogate should copy the 50s wrap
into the cells or not yeah is there was
a movie here but imagine this oil
flowing and blood making top it to make
very many doctors for a second then the
doctors may contain or may not contain
yourself but most of them will contain
cells incubation 10 minutes 37 degrees
it's sugar and here's a zone you can see
several set to drop it in one with a
paddle and Szczesny patil yep hourly and
the counters in their face I'd be the
fluorescence here because using as i
will show you a moment aim him pressure
meter message providers measure them
they accede to the self here as you can
see a similar a show
the toshiba self which is faintly
largest fluorescence from the from there
is not the kind of ability for white
cells which have contributed to include
emitted fluorescence affinity ratios or
drop it but not much yeah I this message
there is a continuous phase
multiplication in the microenvironment
use for a native oil to presenting wait
through fashioned special phase cell
suspensions and then you have values
tick snap to michael moore a semitic
ph-sensitive I just because we do that
and you can flow rate dispersed phase 10
in micro liters per hour cooking phase
for my crazy from our collection plate
time to eliminate the sparrow so we're
still slope you know but I'm going
several panels in parallel we can speed
up the metal a Batali my critics like
this you can use the multi-channel
possibility that you easily have they
are not using them yet because they
still go to a maturation stage with
logic but as a machine it works to
machine at work at present is a second
website have picked up its fortified me
macro in diameter 50p co-leaders
typically are so much smaller than this
well pump a better shockingly the oil
and pushing it because it's very much a
sense how is negative pressure the idea
to it also a [ __ ] less you can have work
on TV then this is what you have you
then after examine the for action coming
from itself dr. goes on the present
yourself yeah well in the right upper
right corner of the slide here also the
sheet of light and get high and you can
take a picture is a salad because this
nurse has made some very few profits get
acidic we have 78 but no condom clear
the cell and lovely and become acidic
then the service counters is no plastic
simple as that so we go further
on some results
another side here
okay here we need to calibrate the
machine first we have this to one single
pilot and two emissions from it
depending on the acidity ratio can
change this first part upper left corner
on slide 32 Peter equal is established
the condition in this way so in yo ratio
one in the droppers are not acidic ph
7.4 and your 7.2 or something and then
yes Evan 6.75 point something and you
see the ratio eks steadily so you can
prop many many point many Peaks good
considering the calibration and you take
is no service in it droplets on there
and you can teach the city without by 58
in dbh in this way a mission can be seen
next slide see that they're ready
precisely lon testing one percent fiscal
arrows and the other commercial yet
change from 7.4 2005 a ph of the old
records now if you can look in the
microscope and try the cells in the
droplet and the cell is acidic then you
can that is tumor cell you can also
shorten it Peaks let me first commit you
that we are looking because we are
looking at
the first have to analyze step sideline
to look it see you will visit white
blood cell line and there's no but
actually recent changes to one or one
point me to 11.5 starting stiff occasion
and can you expose the sugar or 10 News
which is standard 10 years of course and
as you can see if you have a breast
cancer cell line of acidification ratios
up to 42 points are normally large the
bulk of the health english in the region
of 2.5 hours from example positive event
you can see that in the center of each
slide you have eventually ratio changes
some events she even the self-control in
the poor essence in changing then you
see same effect for type of cancer
destin test metastatic carcinoma you can
see ya most of them goes to then some
possibly white white blood cells
participate in the event and it's very
limited the number in year one correct
answer same clients of white blood cells
by only the back of cancer cells is
changing after 2.5 and ovarian cancer
then okusama clear cell growth roof of
the lens
now calibrating incubation time is that
during few minutes ten years saturating
typo so you don't need two more than 10
minutes so this is revenge conference or
she washes relation year because the set
up into the acidic environment I know
the swimming down less are empty
descaler empty sockets now respect the
samples into the blood is a satisfy his
will or blood baskin you you like speed
up the process realize the way hold it
white red blood cells and then yours
from you can speed up again if it also
with viable cells with cd44 fortified
depletion and then you're left with
something like them as a 50,000 sets
unconcerned I'm starting and you have
all the new graphics changes cells in it
this case you start with them yes
example this type you have this case
fans cancer cell you'll enter the uppers
all of Selma up now from the plastic
shelf and then similarly in the left
side Exeter nice blog no no events hey
it's a breast cancer cell spike into the
blood then you see them my usual
established present condition which we
are pushing the blood so we can with a
knife a lot of you
thirty forty percent of years and by
this song says it is appealing to she
put two percent of cells in the blood we
recover only say half percent that's so
important because we don't get any other
patients I know the defects in Ixia
patient samples and help you analyze
both event despite a show you before
need a collection is the 30 patient you
can see same type of the fact Chum cells
are changing like a few now only if you
because even it will be ecstatic
everything started patient they're not
many shells this to these are empty
self-centered or droppers with wipe
yourself conclusions first you can
discriminate between cancer cells in
white and white blood cells this symbol
the table is good enough to do that
spice and what we can take campaign
money sell anything but we have similar
pattern potential shelf line totally a
computer i detecting the cancer cells
however we need to the more additional
data we need to shut up it out so it
possible to show them out measure the
genomics it establishes a same same
Jerome as they as it fell in the tumor
or has changed and the in the
metaphysical same as image a static
thing could begin you the comparison
with patients where biopsy shall be
taking in traffic away compare without a
diaper biopsy eventually when we
confident in early I think you can do
buy houses Oliver in the blood liquid by
oxygen
whatever that I professional degree
belches you can arrive cdna my car and
made a Lay's hello hand stuff and our we
believe it good after selfish more
reliable than well DNA will awaken at
the promoters also and then for only
food sources were much more sensitive
and you can do a good job too it's
important not to have to rely on on
passing with us Oh classic biopsies very
damaging and yeah back in the spread of
the cans per second it especially it
worth it i will say it's likely that i'm
particularly need to compare our job
those are various hepatis spent
differences but consistently cater two
measurements semi ways you know to be
see this point we have the group in my
in my group here has done a different
type of activity has analyzed the
brother of patients breast cancer
patient very slowly very deeply so the
trickle comes some clues about possible
difference latex i would like to thank
the people so far our joke about the
university is a specialist of any
opportunity microfluidics much as rector
and if i would have been the two
students who may you have this work they
have a have such a lot the limited
sending the one who is going to provide
the work of we can about funny she's the
one which we report now
holy sing out on 30 patients enrolled
but then we could make only 60 65
because the grant was stopped escape me
with that judgment they use doctor again
this is any case we have will be able to
do the work 65 patients and their work
role as follows one take Lisa with the
red blood cells incubation with c-45
micro bleach stain antibodies and
acceleration then using a deeper ray the
pearl a machine which is very slow but
very precise asked about 10,000 hem
sickle special to move around itself can
sort them out with them electro electro
physiology movement and very much the
cells before with to telemarketers three
missing 10-month cd45 ebooks we have
been able to realize itself pretty much
clearly and show you now diesel which
cells we would analyze if it was is in
primer one and it will appear red if you
first verse says here is amazing comic
transition bed and dream is repeatedly
only clean questions and this electron
in hell if you said smaller cell as
fluorescence and blow on it this is an
impurity this is all the bad thing for
essence indicate little propel okay so
I mean I set ourselves this way we can
came to clinical validation of the
method by compelling with research
communication we are seated between
chain pathological feature this is
number distribution operation
correlation between CDC gene expression
profile all this thing we were able to
pull eventually also via cells actually
the cheap machine cheap and fast machine
show you before this was done slowly I'm
Elizabeth Webber birthday instead of a
tiempo de las vegas can do we could do
much more kina feature in this way when
they were almost a 30 patients over West
couch and number 15 yourself quality he
is a born was born ball metaphysician
even involving lower number of hidden
camera shells I number epidemia Lauren
humble Mr Cameron said number okay Lisa
said when when there was honey one
number higher number of Patil yourself
and for have two diseases so a number of
cameron said that was all stuffy was
important to establish the face perfect
when basic I'm markers we're together
with a pity that one's so when the
follicle material molecules especially
the Caracas then they that was a call
the blue lines more than fifty percent
of this was em
bad prognosis while also a section is
less than fifty percent of ourselves
would express married biomarkers in
being exterior shell commands of the
number of cities especially the
Callimachus job to be important octopus
balls overall survival commercial fish
11 it's an important finding because
contrary to what resulted beginning but
the mesenchymal tercel ready web bad
news not when you see a more pressing
transition that where they in usual bed
for the patient
factor of the real estate especially the
camera Marcus seems to correlated with a
survivor number she diseases / civilian
callimachus job to be prognostic factor
for her survival and progression-free
survival we need to compare completely
comparison with safesearch patience
level is collaboration with the
exclusion in Padova and just start in
doing it we get patients your blood and
both in power they will do the research
numeration will do how a machine
numeration in a piano then there will be
single cells I just came out in that
case study we opted to get involved all
65 patients tonight so happy that you
originally planned into culture cells
the collaborators in this second part of
the study well that's the Nexus sadly we
should be planning attorney with gramma
calculates the final module onto able to
fold it to mario sorrenti know any
especially capable funny is on eight
percent of the work in this area the
dish your support in islam sit at the
markings of the terrace in padua the
propeller which research michaela
maganda to do they hey pseudo-polynomial
to do the damn genomic additional itself
and Mateo to Little Bay and public been
in our institution and shake shake on
biosystem s in a healthy like terrible
funny with the
d'Epinay would like to thank my wife
your son she's helped me get up spider
vein Parkinson disease you can probably
notice for my speech I be able to be
going around with her she catch me
everywhere and thank you to you I will
happy to take any questions you may have
thank you dr. scold we um we appreciate
your time and we'd love that informative
presentation before we get started on
the question and answer session i just
want to remind our audience how to
submit questions you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
and that is found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we will try to
answer as many questions as we can okay
dr. schools our first question wondering
if the gene signature profile of the CT
ceased indicate if the circulating cells
from the tumor have acquired the
expression profile that is similar to a
specific cell type generated during
chemo tokyo system i am following on the
sending of speech i'm sorry i took it
down to schools um I'm going to read
question number two and if you remember
on the green Q&A button that's on the
bottom left of the screen to green
button with a question mark in it yes
okay if you click on that I'm going to
be reading question number two okay
and if you go to the tagged section what
is great question are you coming uh you
want to go to the tab there's incoming
and tagged okay and we'll start with
question number tails battle on the
agency nurse we profiled CDC's indicated
she couldn't tell for my tumor had
acquired an expression of a senior we
have not yet analyzed expression profile
itself hey Lisa that they hope to be
done pretty fast pretty soon we're not
old yet you've done it in them the
second part of the talk the show
analogies and as you know then special
profiles are senior but by the same he
can change the images respectable family
tumor I said not completely it was to
continue to make assistant this
direction very careful our next question
is going to be was the oxygen level
monitored within the water droplets
which were trapped in the oil oxygen
level could change due to cell
metabolism and can affect the metabolism
of self that's question number four yes
we make sure that is also a reproducible
means that the temperature was kept low
when the metabolic was not to place
languish in tentacles in case the room
temperature for a while and then dropped
again those mute swear so we don't
expect kenya in official changes in
their oxygen concentration because the
result it seems to depend on the time
next question dr. schools how long was
the time between the formation of water
droplets and the observation of the
droplets under microscope I'm between
the information just more question
number five yes I think something like
20 minutes or so Amy next question is
the number 6 can the cancer cells be
fluorescent labeled before spiking the
way you may be able to tell if the
acidic ones are the cancer cells without
sorting the water droplets ouch it
should've been doing that and that's how
we we know basically it can be labeled
then you can get the presence of the
labels and then you can have but you
know what to do that normally repeatedly
because that will change in making the
generalities speed and tend to damage
the cell phone for growth again and for
culturally but if you've done this very
nice work do you think if there is pH
difference inside the cell and
extracellular how about mitochondrion oh
yes yeah they said you don't believe is
also different because then the protons
are getting out with her fast and have
environment that is really large so that
them is faithful it wasn't not to
reenter the cells in my opinion there
will be and 30 question will be no it is
not changed for them quite big
difference between inside and why my
recreation according to the gradient
pair we plan to measure radiance in the
future was so not on
well done yes hey question number eight
dr. schools um we have an audience
member who would like to know if they
have results on breast cancer cell lines
and lung cancer cell line no result the
Kansas a line and long yes we do
recently I started doing some lung
cancer and it's how we hope to have more
significant result because one can feel
difficult to monitor and two it better
well perfectly from it let them yes we
have resolved Wisconsin and lung cancer
cell lines include reaction schools now
there are no more questions I would like
to once again thank dr. Jay Santos goals
for his presentation dr. schools do you
have any final comments for us know or
then I hope very much this matter will
change a way to early detection cancer
for instance because let's say they
article was mentioned to you the one
came out in cancer letters at the
beginning dr first a mentioning lead
that when a good application will be
done early cancer diagnostics because
when you have at cancer appears when we
come and comes in again you have to wait
for the new taxes to establish
themselves and then never lick my chrome
FF is already made hance reliance in the
blood and if you see this you can then
AXA gate this chemotherapy making the
life of the patient much better spy only
remark thank you for the opportunity
talk to you starter schools thank you so
much today's WOD webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
februari 2017 you will receive an email
from lab roots alerting you when this
webcast will be available for replay we
invite you to
forward that announcement to your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live events we appreciate you joining us
and we look forward to seeing you next
time good bye bye bye